pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que le pardon
oh déjà ce n'est plus elle vous est
rendu tout votre chambre et prize et
bien surmonté avec vous monsieur nous
revoici c'est la personne en cause tout
juste d'arriver sur le tabouret c'est
gentil voyait le coach et il fait monter
les malfrats commissionnaires merci
maman je sors
c'est l'ancienne avec champions
du rouge la date il a épousé la veuve
d'un huissier dans la ville non même un
peu de bien là bas appelez moi ça m'est
égal je m'en fiche je suis un artiste ma
faim il ya des gens pour qui tout ça ça
pose la maison
chauffer la de progrès moi faire le gros
dos et le choc des escaliers les
propriétaires qui se respecte mais aussi
l'immeuble est supérieurement fréquenté
au et gaz à tous les étages qui se
croyait avec des gens bien tenez par
exemple ici vous avez le fils du
propriétaire monsieur dame auguste
l'arbre le magasin de soirée que vous
avez vu en bas c'est à lui qu'a ces cas
ci dessus se ne vaut rien comme tout ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui
non c'est l'architecte il dit dufour
c'est qu'on délègue une nouvelle façade
en pierre de taille au vernis l'escalier
trois couches une bon dos rond
peinturlure des appartements complet
c'est le retard de l'époque tu prends
même un bel avenir
le second fils monsieur théophile il est
une très jolie femme
le propriétaire lui même il loge chez
son gendre du verrier et gaillard qui
n'a pas quarante cinq ans et qui est
déjà conseiller la cour d'appel joli
hein
on était là de genre le monsieur est que
de livres c'est pourquoi pas
ce qui paraît
sur un ace
ah la la ici c'est une jeune femme d'un
très rare mérite
tenez vous bien sûr mari l'a quittée
quinze jours après le mariage
je reconnais plus d'une qui après un
drame pareil donner plus de liberté elle
douceur et résignation
elle reçoit que des prêtres la très
jolie st
un instant je me cherchez votre clé lisa
c'est encore moi ford
là encore à l'étagé un couloir et nous y
sommes vous aurez à l'excellent voisins
des gens simples d'accord mais d'un très
bon niveau
le prêt avec les sciers cristallerie de
saint-joseph deux filles à marier par
exemple varier un peu mon neveu
elles auront envie de comptes mails vous
méfiez vous la mer c'est un grand
capitaine campagnes de napoléon à côté
des siennes c'est bien peu de choses si
elle n'a pas varié ses fils n'est pas de
sa faute mais il y arrivera je lui fais
confiance
réparé ici les pichon
et bien voilà je vous ai montré tout ce
qu'il y avait à voir la visite est
terminée voilà chez vous on paye
c'est parfait mon dieu j'ai suivi vos
instructions oui mais là vraiment je
sais pas comment vous remercier c'est
tellement charmant moi je vais 13h hélas
autre chose je suis obligé de vous dire
pas de femmes
vous avez remarqué le genre de la maison
d'après un esclave les gens et on va le
dire monsieur nous nous serions
compromis l'un de l'autre
aussi je vous prie faites le pour moi
sinon pour vous respectez l'immeuble
c'est une condition sinequanone ouais
mais ne craignez rien ceci dit vous
savez je suis artiste je comprends les
choses par exemple c'est pourri si mal
oui oui qui faisait cela bon eh bien je
vous laisse décider comme on voudrait
nous vous attend dans l'escalier avait
rempli au btob de respect il était tout
ému d'habiter une maison si bien selon
l'expression de l'architecte
il alla jusqu'à la fenêtre d'où tombent
et une clarté verdâtre la course en fond
c'est triste propres
avec son pavé régulier sa fontaine dans
le robinet luizet et toujours pas un
être vivant pas un bruit
rien que les fenêtres aux uniformes sans
une cage d'oiseau sans un pot de fleurs
et alan la monotonie de leur rideau
blanc
[Musique]
je suis chez vous vous ne vous ai pas
dit j'étais nommé architecte diocésain
bon une misère m'enfin ça permet de
mettre architectes du gouvernement sur
les cartes de visite et ça c'est
excellent ça me fait rire j'en connais
plus tard plaçant qui s'étendrait à la
vue de ce thème leur phase i pour un
esprit diablement fin diable au nord les
cadets voulez-vous au change en
vieillissant c'est en construisant local
de sable et que j'ai commencé à revenir
à dieu
j'avais des contacts quotidiens avec le
conte un homme très pieux d'une bonté
d'une intelligence universelle est très
influent aussi c'est grâce à lui que
sitôt après je fais le petit séminaire
de la cei et la caserne de henry 15e de
richert quelle affaire je ne demande que
deux comme ça dans ma vie
du coup j'ai fait mais pâques avec
l'entrepreneur almas moi vous vous êtes
france c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça les voiles la providence mon cher
elles sont toujours aussi mystérieuse
c'était docteur dieu change de méthode
avec la nature de chacun de nous moi je
n'ai pas honte de le dire il m'a
littéralement acheter quand on pense
vous voulez il y aura mis le paquet dans
le fond le trouve plutôt ça flatte et là
j'entends docteur qui sont excusés
à paroles comme il a grandi mais j'ai 22
ans et c'est un homme vous donnerait
facilement trois de plus est ce que vous
vous rappelez avec gaspard in lorsque
vous vous amusez à me déguiser en fille
oui oui et beaux parents comment
vont-ils a très bien très bien je vous
remercie ma lampe qui depuis son jardin
vous retrouverez la maison de la rue de
la base tels que vous l'aviez quitter
pourquoi changer ce qui est charmant
aller le temps c'est bien où il faut
s'arrêter
oui et bien voici votre pensionnaires
savez vous avez été annonce vous occuper
de tout ne me remerciez pas c'est
achille cas tout fait moi je suis bien
trop paresseuse je ne bouge plus oui
c'est ce qu'il m'a dit vous êtes
souffrent il affirme même le docteur
juillerat ne sais pas ce que j'ai et
parlant de vous ce sera plus gai qu'est
ce qui vous a donné l'idée de venir à
paris
la fortune j'ai gagné 5000 francs 5000
francs racontez moi ça ne savait
peut-être que je travaille dans une
maison de tissus à marseille
bon il avait la figure et vous une
indienne pompadour un vieux dessins une
merveille ascension qui traînait là
depuis deux ans dans les cas personne ne
mordent alors que je devais faire le var
et les basses aux abris
j'ai eu l'idée de racheter toulon et de
le revendre à mon compte
le succès les femmes s'arrachent aimé
coupons n'y en a pas une aujourd'hui
kiné de mon indienne sur le corps moi
votre indienne s'était pas des petits
bouquets sur fond écru gris
j'en ai cherché partout pour impayés
marc dtm envoyé à mme fr le voyageur
pendant deux ans et c'est assez mais
pour ça il était temps partir la
conquête de paille
mon dieu ça peut se faire vous avez un
plan on peut savoir comment comptez vous
vous y prendre
si je vous dis par des femmes vous serez
choqués certainement bien vous ne
devriez pas parce que le simplement dire
que j'ai l'intention de rester dans la
même branche privée mais j'adore les
tissus et les étoffes la présence
constante des fans là je me sens dans
mon élément
mon dieu je crois une peau de satin des
yeux de velours décile de soi les dents
vous même tout un magasin de nouveautés
réussi à limoges à l'octave mais
attention la cliente c'est une chose
la femme s'en est une autre dangereux
ici très dangereux vous piloterez
comment le pourrais-je quand je suis
tombé sur mon canapé
mais moi j'ai un bandeau devant les yeux
le bandeau de la province la veuve et le
paralytique ça peut marcher
soit deux décès ont alors quel est votre
premier conseil ne vous retournez jamais
non
le dîner fut assez agréable mais octobre
fatigué du voyage demandent à la
permission de se coucher de bonne heure
ce qui lui fut facilement accordées par
des gens qui avaient des habitudes très
régulière l'escalier s'endormaient dans
une chaleur lourde
il semblait plus recueillie que jamais
avec ses portes chaste ses portes de
riches acajou fermé sur les alcôves
zanette pas assouplir le passé c'était
un silence de gens bien élevés qui
retiennent jusqu'à leur souffle
e
[Musique]
m
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis tout s'abîme à la maison tomba dans
la solennité des ténèbres comme man et
anti dans la distinction et la décence
de son sommeil
la première journée l'octave apparaît
était terminée
[Musique]
comme ils se sentaient loin de plaçant
comme il était calme comme il était
heureux
[Musique]
un chien
qu'est ce que vous faites là donc on
peut vous croyez qu'on va prendre une
voiture pour dépenser 200 soudier et de
mai pour souligner est bien quand vous
n'aurez plus de sou lire vous resterez
au lit ces avances de vous sortir aller
à quoi les passes on est donc obligé de
savoir que je parle de madame de
couilles c'est pas gentil bon allez
marche mais marié qu'à nous a sortis
pour on sait simplement que ça ne ratait
pas toujours un bel exemple une
malheureuse qu'il a fallu mettre six
mois dans un couvent pour la blanche y
voient plutôt bien que je puisse moi
dans la rue c'était le temps paraît
justement de vue ce carré et bien on
n'est pas très bon ça vaut pas 40 sous
l'avion - berck comme les autres allons
bon papa maintenant oui celui là si
c'était à refaire un homme dont je suis
encore à attendre la première des
attractions aller
manquait à on vous annonce que mariage
est raté et vous moi c'est tout ce que
vous trouvez à dire non non c'est très
ennuyeux ennuis 7,1 me rendre à fun
arrêtez vos gribouillis mais ma bonne
jeu je fais mes bandes à 3 francs en
2003 france et 3 francs 6 c'est là
dessus que vous mentez vous tirer
d'affaires ça paiera toujours vos gardes
ton repose chez moi mais mardi tant que
vous y êtes si sans doute pour mon
plaisir que je garde tous ces imbéciles
de brioches et de crème fouettée
non mais est ce que par hasard vous
imaginez que ce n'est rien de mariée vos
de bécasses qu'est ce que vous avez fait
là bas quand on ne danse pas hommage aux
héros c'est une élection
adele ne voyons jamais l'avenir ont peur
de nous quel torchon cette fois vu les
vielles la vaisselle d'avant-hier don
juan je vous fait la fiche informative
sera bien avancée même les bonnes
chassés de partout veulent pas venir
dans un endroit où tout est compté
morceaux de sucre café quand tu seras
marié tu feras ce que tu voudras j'en ai
assez de voir des peignes dans la huche
à pain et de manger des frigos qui me
donne la colique vu tu ne trouves rien
là dedans j'ai tout lapin qui reste
hélas que ça y est voilà il est froid
mais je le prends ça fait rire
maintenant qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans ça
fond de confiture de groseilles que j'ai
mis à des ligues où c'est toujours ça de
pris
mais qu'est ce que je vais donner à mes
invités onemain de l'eau sans doute
demain c'est demain c'est sa vie tout le
pont
dites moi vous vous pouvez rien dire
sans crier c'est vous qui avait permis à
dell de faire ses comptes surnom
lamartine non alors est prise à ce son
bonnet
dites moi
en rentrant du bureau vous ferez le
plaisir d'aller chez les camps pardon et
leur rappeler nous comptons sur eux pour
demain soir le jeune homme est arrivé
hier briller les de l'amener ses
sérieuses veut qu'il vienne
quel jeune homme un peu maigre comme
renseignements fait d'accord avec vous
il faut bien j'essaie tout puisque vous
me lâcher vos deux filles comme un
paquet de sottises de là à les donner à
n'importe qui a je vous en prie 1
ne venez pas me mettre de bâtons dans
les roues aux mais ce que j'étais né
mois pour une vie sans le sou c'est ma
faute peut-être parfaitement on n'épouse
pas une femme quand on a décidé de la
laisser manquer tout mais vous faisiez
le fanfaron vous posiez à l'homme
d'avenir à vous croire
vous étiez l'ami des berne m encore deux
qui sont bien faits chute vous savez
vous ce que j'aurais fait moi votre
place j'aurais mis plusieurs fois la
maison dans ma poche
voilà ce que j'aurais fait avec la
confiance que vous inspirez rien été
plus facile pardon pardon mais vous me
reprocher d'être honnête
qu'appelez-vous honnêteté soyez d'abord
honnête envers moi
les autres ne doivent pas c'est
qu'ensuite il me semble bref pour un
homme honnête
vous m'avez filouter d'une jolie façon
si j'avais seulement connu votre famille
tu devrais aller se coucher leur nord ma
famille ne t'a rien fait là sa
tranquille et pourquoi donc s'il vous
plaît elle n'est pas plus sacrée qu'une
autre personne n'ignore a clairement que
votre père s'est ruiné pour une
blanchisseuse nous aurions marienneau
fuit depuis longtemps s'il n'avait pas
couru les jupons à plus de 70 ans
encore un qui meurt fait ne nous sont
pas nos familles à la tête a le temps ça
vaudra mieux
alors parce que si tu vas par là le
canevas jamais payé ta doc quoi madhat
parfaitement
alors mon père a peut-être eu des
malheurs mais le tien s'est conduit
d'une façon parce que si la pension de
la rue saint victor est allé au mari de
sa soeur ce plan rap et il nous salue
même plus je t'interdis de dire du mal
de papa bon je n'insinue rien mais nous
avons été volés comme dans un à boire je
te l'interdît tu m'entends papa qui a
été l'honneur de l'enseignement pendant
plus de quarante ans va parler de
l'institution bachelard autour du
panthéon
peut-être quant à ma soeur et à mon
beau-frère ils sont ce qu'ils sont ils
m'ont volé je le sais c'est pas toi de
le dire un salon par exemple que je te
parles de ta soeur moi à quoi ma soeur
tu n'as plus de seurre tout d'un coup tu
as heard et ang lee qui s'est sauvé avec
un officier un officier qu'il a épousée
madame sans vouloir être méchant
j'aimerais pouvoir en dire autant de
l'oncle bassam et vous devenez fou
monsieur mon frère est riche il gagne ce
qu'il veut dans la commission et il a
promis de doter berthe vous ne respectez
dont rien voulez vous pariez qu'il ne
donnera pas un franc annocer un
profiteur qui m'emmène tous les samedis
à son bureau pour vérifier ses comptes
ça lui fait toujours l'économie de sens
où nous en sommes encore à connaître la
couleur de ces cadeaux vous avez bien un
neveu dans la police vous pourtant baulu
mille francs pas seulement voilà rien il
vous suffit vous avez la rage de
recevoir et de rendre des visites
ça fait un mois dans une boîte tant que
vous y êtes et vos films ceux qui
pousseront elle si elle ne voit personne
n'y a pas foule déjà sacrifié vous voilà
comment vous remercie tu ne se
sacrifient pas pourquoi avoir fait des
filles ce n'est pas moi qui voulais
demander un
alors puisque elles sont là n'ont pas
leur reprocher leur éducation
d'autres à votre place se glorifie ray
du brevet de capacité d'hortense des
talents de berthe est encore ravi tout
le monde ce soir avec sa valse des bords
de l'oise mais vous non tenez vous
n'êtes même pas un père jean verrier vos
enfants garder les vaches
au lieu de les mettre à l'école ce qui
n'empêche que j'ai pris une assurance
sur la tête de berthe
seulement quatrième versement vous vous
êtes servi de l'argent pour recouvrir
les meubles du salon et depuis vous avez
même négocié les primes versées
certes puisque vous nous laissez mourir
de faim vous pourrez vous mordre les
doigts si vos filles coiffe sainte
catherine
mais me mordre les doigts je ne vois pas
pourquoi mais tonnerre de dieu si vous
madame vous qui fait fuir les maria avec
vous vos toilettes et et vos soirées
ridicule ridicule c'est froid chez nous
où mes enfants c'est rien de le dire ça
vous gêne les manceaux dans la bouche la
papillonneuse c'est déjà quelque chose
je veux bien qu'on me coupe la main si
je vais encore une paire de gants pour
les sortir à votre tour et tâcher de ne
pas être plus ridicule que moi
or bleu et pauvre petit maintenant que
vous les avez sorti est compromise parts
ont marié l'une les marchés pas je m'en
fiche et moi donc si vous vous en fichez
je m'en fiche encore plus que vous je
m'en fiche même tellement que je vais
était flanqué dans la rue vous allez
voir ça vous pourrez les suivre si le
coeur vous en dit la porte restera
ouverte au seigneur qu'elle débarras ça
fait peur de vous disputer moment ce but
le teint pas pas encore être malin de
bio
tu as une autre solution mais laissez
nous faire consommer ces grandes pour
nous débrouiller tout seul ben voila
voila on n'y avait pas pensé
si tu parle pour toi tu es assez godiche
pau verdier ne déposera jamais eh bien
nous verrons
hortense ma chérie je t'ai déjà demandé
de renoncer à ce projet mais tu connais
la situation il va la quitter pour
femmes après quinze ans de ménage ces
malheureuses retourne toujours au
ruisseau seulement c'est verdier qui
n'aura pas le courage de rompre te le
fais croire c'est tout je le veux je
leur ai
la tête c'est hortense pas tu ferais
bien de te taire qu'est ce que tu as
encore fait pour rater ce mariage sous
chef de bureau à 30 ans à l'avenir
superbe tous les mois ça vous apporte
son argent c'est solide y'a qu'ça pas
encore fait quelques impairs et pourtant
partie bien brutalement prévenu mais mon
temps dans le petit bureau il a voulu de
vilaines choses
alors forcément que pousser contre un
meuble poussée contre un meuble mais il
m'a fait pas aussi avec ses yeux ils
vont a dit qu'il pouvait manger la
manger c'était cuit il l'a poussée
contre nous c'est fini
moi j'en peux plus j'abandonne moment
qu'est ce que tu voulais que je fasse je
pouvais quand même pas le laisser faire
or ne me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai
pas dit un homme ça doit être remis à sa
place ça c'est sûr et fermement on peut
être ferme sans être à droite pousse le
contre un meuble si tu veux mais arrange
toi pour tomber avec lui passion lui
tout de même
tiens il fallait qu'elle tombe celle là
saturnin qu'est ce que tu fais non
qu'est ce qui se passe et le tabac tue
mais non c'est rien si rien n'est pas
couché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis avant tout de suite vous
rappelez mademoiselle gasparini caisse
marine de place les premières demoiselle
j'ai justement parler d'elle avec votre
femme il ne se voit plus alors il ya
comme ça dans les familles débrouille
personne n'y comprend plus rien mais si
vous me croyez ne nous en mêlons pas de
nous en mêlons laissons faire le temps
lui seul peut le guérir les blessures
je vous présente mon ami octave mouret
dont je vous ai parlé
vous connaissez le métier monsieur moore
est oui j'ai travaillé chez châtillon à
marseille oui c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre que j'ai apporté de
certificats inutile la recommandation de
monsieur campardon suffit comment va
madame qu'en partant toujours pareille
arrive très visité la maison quand avez
vous commencé
moi je suis à 20 entre mana demain
demain excusez moi bon je vous laisse je
vous retrouve ici nord du dont un quart
d'heure vingt minutes allait très bien
octave bourrel nouveau premier inutile
de voiliers en mon nom je m'en vais
c'est moi que vous remplacez ah bon et
vous ne vous plaignez pas ici vous
trouverez peut-être le moyen de
réveiller la maison moi j en ans c'est
trop vieux trop vieux
bonjour bonjour les apprentis ou des
rebelles c'est comme partout les garçons
coup dans leurs rayons les demoiselles
salima theron les petites chambres
grenier
bonjour tu permets
mais le nouveau premier voilà ton
arrangement est très joli essai mais moi
je le trouve un peu un peu trop jolie
alors tu feras plutôt quelque chose
comme ça vous croyez que le cueillait
entre wire neurones avec l'important ce
n'est pas ce qu'elle regarde c'est ce
qu'elle voit quand le tissu qu'elles ont
envie d'acheter il faut qu'ils leur
saute aux yeux
rien d'autre ne compte
grand monsieur campardon vous cherche
oui oui je viens de voir entrer jeu
mademoiselle gaspard in mais
dépêchez-vous je sais pas s'il est
encore avant merci je te jure que non
toujours pareil elle semble maintenant
que j'ai fait je ne se remettra jamais
mon pauvre c'est toi qui as plaindre
heureusement que tu as pu s'arranger
entre eux
viens demain 6h
je resterai coucher
la voilà tout est arrangé
vous avez vu malone et doit elle est
très impressionnant d'abord on va mon
petit coeur au trésor j'ai une bien
mauvaise nouvelle pour octave monsieur
josserand est venu tout à l'heure et il
a insisté pour que tulameen ce soir à la
réception
j'avais oublié les mois qui justement un
train à prendre demain à l'aube pour
evreux ne l'avait pas dit bonjour se
décider au dernier moment si ça te
contrats et autres biens au maître
normand trésor va pas rejouer avant ta
maîtresse mais leur antre pas trop tard
la dernière fois je m'inquiéterais jeu
pour 2 heureusement tellement négligent
littoraux qui
mon secret
à votre santé et votre fait
bien sûr la tâche est rude
voilà n'ont fait bien câliner g
compiègne encore un fait vraiment et un
an elle est excellent merci ça va rester
dans le muscadet motorisé un tonneau de
vin s'est fait à la maison mon septième
temps mais qu'est ce que vous attendez
les assiettes chaudes vite barras et
nous donnait rien pour notre rythme
tiens c'est vrai ça on donne toujours
quelque chose pour sa fête au fait
qu'elle fit l'époque on nous appelait
pas un artiste peut être je m'appelle
bachelard et ça monsieur narcisse bâche
la perte de ses pouvoirs et je veux tu
as tout geste gros loup j'ai reçu de
marseille 12 de vieira pour les jeunes
qui comme nous vous êtes folle va franc
s'est pas fait l'info nous c'est sans
doute acquis mais vous savez le laisser
tranquille
pourquoi donc elle s'amuse si narcisse
vous leur donnez 20 francs c'est bien
son rang
il fait du entre man show entre deux
pièces créées comme l'angoissé jolie de
tromper son monde vous n'auriez pas
qu'elles sont en baisse mais non valeur
d'un franc par est ignoble individu pour
l'un francs j'en suis malade je vous en
prie
[Rires]
elle vise à bousculer non non ce n'est
rien et d'une maladresse
si vous voulez vous ça débute je ne vais
pas encore formé ça pourrait se faire
lâcher pas besoin d'argent je vous jure
la demande et agulla o rei blague c'est
toi qui a payé au café riche c'est vrai
oui oui et ça c'est bien d'autres
chevrier
[Applaudissements]
c'est michel catésis total au sens fort
non non vous exagérez
baudard connaissait ancien comptable de
la gare du nord
celui qui a marqué sa fille l'année
dernière oui dieu sait s'il était
heureux et bien il vient de découvrir
que son gendre était un ancien clown il
a vécu dix ans au crochet d'une cuillère
j'ai eu mal j'étais obligé de l'enfermer
mais j'ai peur qu'ils cassent tout dans
sa chambre laissant avis je le fish à
l'asile verte ma chérie tu occupes toi
de monsieur moore est qu il pourrait
regretter son midi devant tout ce qu'on
lui a posé les vents tournent donc je ne
crois pas à côté de camidi êtes vous
monsieur mouret du jour est plaçant le
haut var
alors
il me semble que l'on se défend mieux
contre le froid que contre le show mais
pourquoi voulez-vous vous défendre
peut-être pour mieux céder mais pas bon
de boire avant d'avoir soif
eh bien je vais suivre votre conseil
tout à l'heure peut-être
vous avez raison tout n'est pas de la
meilleure qualité dans la maison je vous
dirai ce qu'il faut boire
ah bon bravo vous êtes nattés et même si
vous êtes un pauvre petit être sans
défense il vaudrait mieux que vous
partiez c'est pas pour rien quand vous
apprenez sirop de groseilles
ils vont essayer de vous refiler une des
deux filles pour tout vous dire c'est
moi donc il fera pas je ris mais dans le
fond ce n'est peut-être pas tellement
gentil pour moi c'est le franchir bon
c'est pas tout ça mais je suis si
fatiguée j'ai passé ma nuit à faire des
grâces et des façons j'en ai par dessus
la peine monsieur vous mourrez épouse et
moi ne me posais pas je m'en bats pour
pourquoi pas tiens mais d'où vient-il
celui là je viens je viens je suis
désolé chez populaire plutôt je suis
débordée c'est en rose c'est le seul
[Musique]
mois bien
tarbes le plus maigre le grand celui qui
a une figure de mouton malade c'est
l'aîné 33 ans et des migraines à n'en
plus finir
l'autre le petit vieux de 28
théophile pour les guerriers du site et
orgueilleux parce qu'il est bête parce
que l'état est très très mal
vous connaissez tous le monde ici je
crois nous allions commencer je suis
ferme
ouais il paraît il ya des hommes qui ça
suffit doit être difficile à oublier
section visage nerveux
vous vous êtes en train de vous égarer
si vous voulez pas vous perdre dans le
labyrinthe
suivez votre ami trubilo les bonnes mon
cher les bornes d'accès de bonnes mais
bien sûr le fil d'ariane c'est très joli
mais c'est long ça fait des me au
seigneur les ça casse
tandis que le site d'ernestine oudaden
on dirait des nouvelles à peine de vous
tirer dessus vous êtes arrivé vous en
voulez qu'est ce que c'est des grains de
café
octave et berthe après 30 ans de mariage
[Rires]
écueil octave mieux tout est dosé
d'avoir déjà 50 ans et vertes elles
manquent chacun sait on parle que
commenter
pourtant j'étais assez franches par
moments le diable me pousse pour chaque
fois que je fais quelque chose de bien
moi c'est grâce à dire et quand vous
dites la vérité le diable mais quand
vous n'êtes pas le diable exigeant par
exemple quand je m'oppose de mariage de
ma soeur qui veut s'établir sur les
ruines d'un coup fil diable encore
toujours le diable quand je désobéis à
mes parents berthe ma chérie c'est à toi
j'y vais bouchez vous les oreilles
surtout sinon vous allez succomber sous
mon charme an passé maman qualité vous
devez aimer la musique
monsieur moore ait beaucoup madame c'est
un morceau sans prétention mais berthe
le joue avec beaucoup d'art oui et
beaucoup d'esprits j'en suis sûr
approché par les un tas
verte ma chérie ne trouble pas monsieur
sera indulgent et puis le piano ça ne
trompe pas ça n'est pas comme la
peinture où l'on vous met sous le nez
des tableaux retouchée par le professeur
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
on
e
vous
jours
[Musique]
tous
et la 10e mesure opta n'est pas plus
qu'il regardait l'auditoire l attention
poliment distraite des hommes et leur
avis m'affecter des femmes toute cette
détente déjà rendu à eux mêmes repris
par les soucis de chaque heure dont
l'ombre remonter dans leurs visages
fatigués octave fini par s'intéresser à
valérie il revenait toujours à l
inquiète séduit quand même
tandis que les yeux vague énervé par
l'aigre musique elle avait le sourire
détraqué d'une malade
pas
il
[Musique]
e
oh
[Applaudissements]
ça
la porte de la cuisine va vite
saturnales c'est adele il n'y a pas
moyen de lui faire fermer ses portes
morten le meilleur moment ça a été
encore l'arrivée du docteur doctes
spécialistes de la femme d'ailleurs vous
lier tous les maris qu'ils approchent
pour le taper d'une consultation et à
propos qui savait tout pourriez
peut-être me dire de quelle maladie
souffre dans le camp perdant
moi je vois tout le monde prendront une
figure désolé qu'entre mon cher pour lui
ce n'est pas drôle
vous savez ce qu'est arrivée la suite de
couches
il parle sûrement le berthe
je crois qu'elle bible et beaucoup qui
ça m'étonne que vous n'ayez jamais pensé
à lui pour votre fille je sais qu'il
cherche quelqu'un il la dévorait des
yeux
l'idée majeure de bourran c'est un
garçon posé est bien établie et qui se
laissera prendre facilement tandis que
le bo provençal on jurerait pas prendre
et puis berthe le déteste et je n'y a
jamais quand tu ressentes caire où la
regardait encore doit avoir un sacré
tempérament
croyez-vous qu'on pourrait s'y risquer
si vous aimez les fils mais pourquoi
s'intéresser à la madrague
quand vous avez sa caméra je vous en
ferai venir à bout enfin de toute façon
ça vaudra mieux que l'épousé l'équipe
qui va demoiselle jeu sera vous êtes
vous aviez lu en augmentant tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure
mais quand j'ai vu vers dessus de piano
la gueule la vie de la mère qui me
regardait avec des yeux de fauves a fait
croyez moi j'étais guérie
arteta ça monsieur auguste tâche d'être
aimable tu m'as compris mort et c'est
fini je ne veux plus entendre parler de
ce voyou
je vais vous cherchez votre manteau et
puis ou à la cuisine
je vous ai assez but tu te fais encore
de la bile moment ça ne me donne pas là
c'est moi je suis contente
ils achètent des chemises pour qu'elle
s'en aille qu'est-ce que ça pauvre des
chemises mène sa barque comme je mène la
mienne puis on verra à l'arrivée tu sais
voilà une brioche qui peut se flatter
d'être mauvaise pour pas qu'ils soient
des gouttes étaient invités pour
engloutir des saletés pareil le plus
souvent c'est pas tellement pour
l'argent si pour la manière
tu sais comment je suis avec les femmes
j'en donnerai tout tout ce que j'ai et
je veux pas qu'elle demande demande ça
me vexe jan fischer a dit qu'on a promis
pourtant des radis à la petite jusque
sur la tombe de notre pauvre mère et ben
justement puisque j'ai promis est-ce que
ça suffit pas pour toi si exactement
bons joueurs qu'ils croient qu'on vient
de me marier ici ans le mari battu peut
chercher mon pauvre saturnin puisque je
te dis que ça a raté ses biens par ap
toujours en je ne peux plus supporter ce
mot-là raté on entend que ça dans cette
maison aa bien je vous jure que le
prochain ça ne rattrape pas quand je
devrais la tâche et moi même par la pâte
y en a un qui va payer pour les autres
oui vous pouvez me regarder avec des
yeux ronds monsieur j'apprends la noce
se fera sans vous si ça vous déplaît du
matin verte
tu vas me le ramasser celui là entre2000
grain ce sera donc voir bien vains pour
va
on m'a même pas laissé une brioche
[Musique]
beaucoup
le jeune octave mourey est monté à paris
pour faire fortune
ses amis campardon lui ont trouvé une
chambre dans l'immeuble où il habite rue
de choiseul c'est une maison bien sous
tous les rapports dean et heureuse
seul problème les filles josserand leur
mère remue ciel et terre pour les mariés
au pta avait été sollicité mais il
s'intéresse bien davantage à la
provocante valérie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
heureusement que le vieux monsieur n'a
pas vu ça tout y est là oui j'ai failli
y intervenir mais quand j'ai vu que vous
vous débrouillez très bien tout seul on
finit par avoir l'habitude je me suis
toujours demandé si c'était une chose
agréable ou désagréable aux femmes ce
genre d'événement plutôt agréable
finalement c'est un hommage vous
encourager à vous présenter le mien mais
d'une façon tout respectueuse bien sûr
merci
elle a réussi
il est plein d'idées le mari dans la vie
des coulisses à la
quant à la femme mais est-ce qu'elle est
jolie ou non plus nous artistes nous
dirions qu'il aurait dû cacher qu'elle
m'intrigue
elle a beaucoup de mérite à l'est ce
n'est pas drôle de vivre avec un homme
tremblant la fièvre et qui est souvent
désagréable et comme moi société le fil
un crétin à puissant avec moi confiance
et qui n'a pas volé ce qui lui arrive
comment avait parfaitement compris mais
dit tout à l'heure on avait dit que
madame vabres était une femme une
gourgandine n'y a pas d'autre mot elle a
des excuses avec un autre homme ce
serait pareil c'est sa nature
et quand la nature et la haye a rien à
faire ça vous emporte noter que c'est un
peu l'impression qu'elle ne fait à
présent vous savez tout ça ce sont des
potins comment et puis les potins nul
n'y échappe
hélas même pas les vabre qui sont
pourtant des genres et spectacles wac
yahouédéhou à notre époque on ne
respecte plus rien car seniors qui s'est
fait faire son petit camille par un
boucher de la rue sainte-anne non il n'y
a pas de preuve pas trop qu'est ce qu'il
faut d'ailleurs leurs logos ou n'avez
qu'à le regarder quand il court et
devient tout rouge
c'est signé sa non tu fais la mauvaise
c'est une hystérique une femme du sud
bousculés mais qui sait qu'il y en a qui
c'est qui vient dire bonsoir à son papa
ça ma mort c'est un geste
bonsoir mâcha gros dodo alain pichon
deviendra reprendre demain matin pour
aller où tu dribbles un malade sa c'est
une belle passe pas rose que c'est une
perle
certainement aussi faut voir comme le
marié et heureux quel joli petit ménage
s'il en était autrement les garderait
pas dans la maison
les pigeons ne sont pas les vagues
parole
le jour où ma fille est exposé à
rencontrer de ces créatures dans
l'escalier je donne mon congé sur le
champ ce soir-là il conduisait
secrètement la cousine gaspard in à
l'opéra comique
aussi elle a t-il bientôt chercher son
chapeau en parlant d'une affaire qui le
retiendrait très tard amuse toi bien
et surtout on prend parfois à la sortie
[Applaudissements]
ce pauvre achille
il n'est encore jamais compris comment
je devine tout ce qu'il essaye de me
cacher comment vous devinez absolument
tout et comment faites vous
sa pomme d'adam pour marquer quand il
ment elle monte et descend dans sa gorge
l'émotion sans doute excusez moi d'être
aussi un discret mais il sent que vous
prenez la chose très bien ah oui bien
sûr c'est la vie c'est en tout cas la
nôtre
super madame vous oui je ne suis permet
de l'attacher mungur vous est destiné
merci beaucoup mais pas de quoi il
fallait pas vous déranger
bon ça
monsieur le rat je me demandais enfin
pourriez vous me dire si vous
accepteriez une tasse de café
non moi j'avais enfin palacio à pleuvoir
état mais au moins je pleurais à faire
je vous en prie monsieur murray soit si
ça vous fait en place et le voilà
[Applaudissements]
à monsieur excusez moi je suis toujours
dehors les parents de ma femme monsieur
madame guillaume je n'ai pas encore pu
vous remercier à le long do c'est
vraiment rien si si si si c'est très
gentil à vous d'avoir accompagné ma
femme comme ça quatre étages veiller
dans vous asseoir il est toujours
agréable d'avoir de bons voisins coûté
si c'est assez sucré j'aime qu'il fait
oui j'en ai rarement vu d'aussi beaux de
la cat et pas monsieur son café bombée
il y en a de meilleur et voiliers de
suite comme elle a été fier et la fierté
ne vaut rien n'exagérons rien voyez-vous
monsieur on m'a décoré à l'âge de 60 ans
le jour même de ma retraite
trente neuf ans de bons et loyaux
services en qualité de comme dirait
d'acteurs au ministère de l'instruction
publique
eh bien vous me croirez si vous voulez
les dîners ce soir là comme les autres
vous
l'orgueil la changer en rien mes
habitudes en raison de la graine mon
genre
enfin sans devoir le gouvernement fait
le sien en 36 ans vous en réseau si
votre récompense il faudra y arriver
ce sont les enfants qui sont lourds
aussi je vous ai dit un seul il ya des
ouvriers pour pondre des petits comme
les poules
eux ils ne s'occupent pas de savoir ce
que ça coûte et voulait lâche sur le
pavé va comme je te pousse un vrai trop
peau de bête quand je les rencontre ça
m'écoeure je détourne la tête
vous avez des enfants peut-être
non non mais tu peux marié vous verrez
c'est une responsabilité
surtout quand on a une fille une
demoiselle on s'est toujours de trop
c'est bien mon avis cette conversation
ne doit guère intéressé monsieur moore
et ce n'est pas tant semaine il
intéresse alors voir et vous monsieur da
18 ans passé ma fille n'avait pas encore
lu un seul roman c'est vrai ou c'est pas
vrai mari aussi vous n'imaginez pas
l'effet du premier un mois avant son
mariage
je lui ai prêté andrée de jorge sans
c'est pourtant un bon roman qui élève
l'âme
eh bien monsieur vous me croirez si vous
voulez elle a pleuré pendant trois jours
sans parler des nuits exact elle
pleurait jusque dans son sommeil c'est
si beau j'aimerais bien de relire
mais qu'est ce qui vous en empêche nous
ça nous abonner au cabinet soysal mais
on leur a volé abel et campardon
toujours jeu sand
si votre mari le père mais je leur
demande répond je ne prenais pas cette
peine c'est très sain entre voisins ce
sont des services qu'on peut se rendre
n'est ce pas attention
[Musique]
mapa nom n'aurait plus jamais une
occasion comme mardi dernier l'agent
j'aurais dû carrément rentrer chez elle
et j'ai pas osé mais vous ne pouvez pas
la dirigez vous annonce la bbc la porte
des pulsions est toujours ouvert non ça
m'ennuie d'ailleurs pas je perds du
temps pour voir
monsieur monsieur même est très raide eu
trop de mal
o une femme qui est déjà pas si solide
c'est injuste sa maladie sa frappe
toujours les gens qui sont pas bien
portants des décèle du vinaigre quelque
chose eh oui quelque chose ce ballet
ou s'en tenir
oui j'étais confuse c'est lui qui est
allé vous cherchez excusez là là du père
de la tête des travaillistes il depuis
quelques jours c'est ridicule honteux
mais anna aller chercher le docteur
juillet gras oui madame tout de suite et
vous passerez prévenir monsieur dans le
36 de la rue d'anjou qui ne rentrent pas
trop tard bienvenue
divia j'avais souvent de ce malaise oui
depuis l'âge de 14 ans c'est un taux
dans les rats tente ou dans les bras les
docteurs ghosn estime le docteur ils
disent rien soit fatigué de drogués
le taux est de s'y faire avec de la
patience on arrive à tous et bien je
croirai plus tôt aux vertus de
l'impatience c'est croire aux vertus de
vis vous la comprenez saison quoi
l'impatience une version l'ardeur
enthousiasme oui c'est le mot que
j'attendais d'eux merci
mais qu'est ce qui vous prend je ne
pense qu'à vous le jour la nuit
georges
oh
oui et c'est moi enfin pourquoi vous
défendez vous vous aussi vous en mourrez
d'envié
moi si vous saviez vous ne croyez pas
que vous aussi vous auriez besoin d'air
vous trouverez tout ce qu'il vous faut
dehors
vous prenez que je jure de rien vraiment
derrière
vous lisez toujours andré c
c'est à vous que je dois ses douze
émotions merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en avais de la chance n'est pas
heureux
je crève d'ennui c'était pas ma
situation il ya longtemps je serais
rentré à marseille
marc yevou
[Musique]
c'est vous qui me dit ça
vous ennuyer plus que moi n'est pas dire
que c'est rigolo ces deux villes
je t'en penses quelquefois le soir je
sais même plus ce que j'ai fait dans la
journée
on est bien d'accord évidemment l'idéal
quand j'étais jeune je voulais habitait
au fond des bois je rêvais que je
rencontre un chasseur qui ce n'est du
corps il se mettait à genoux
c'est ce passé très loin dans un taillis
il ya eu des roses comme dans un parc et
on se mariait c'est un sujet de
ballaigues vous me racontez là je me
trouvais ridicule franchement oui mais
avec des idées par et vous allez passer
à côté de la vie lui j'y passe j'ai
souvent l'impression d'être en marge de
ma propre vie comme ces petits ânes qui
trottine dans la poussière d'or de la
route
mais pourquoi pas si je me trouve bien
tous les petits vous semblait fatigué
actuelle si ça vous fera du bien
je crois que j'en ai encore donc la tête
john bond vers l'asie pour le team pour
j'en suis
c'est ça voyez vous qui me touche dans
les romans les endroits où les
personnages se font des déclarations
ouais moi moi moi les phrases je trouve
ça idiot quand on sème le mieux c'est le
seul prouver tout de suite
trouvez pas vous avez peut-être raison
je n'ai pas été élevé à cette école
parlons-en de votre éducation c'est que
j'ai connu deux demoiselles visser mais
voilà je n'aime pas le droit de mme
accoudé à la fenêtre
j'avais du soufre et santé beaucoup
d'affection autour de moi pour un enfant
c'est l'essentiel et la distraction
journal de modeste elle j'ai censuré par
ma mère et à l'endos s'il fait
qu'aujourd'hui encore je peux avoir une
rature quelque part sans rougir jusqu'à
la pointe des cheveux tu mourrais poney
nous puissions honorer certains n'ont
pas d'objection
[Musique]
il
je
[Musique]
il ose
bien trempé
[Musique]
oh
e
[Musique]
le seigneur
oh
voilà
[Musique]
e
répétons fait mal
[Musique]
à
en
non
là
tong
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
messieurs bravo vous êtes surpasser
c'est notre faute c'est un piège nous
ayons en attendant il a réussi à
compromettre ses petites chaufferies
jamais une tâche dans la famille on peut
en faire chez les autres dans les loges
à mon frère me les crimes étaient encore
ce matin bertora 50 mille francs le jour
de son mariage n'est pas grand chose
bien sûr mais quand l'argent est là
c'est solide
qu'est ce qui te prend de dire des
choses pareilles
tu es folle feriez mieux d'aller voir
monsieur va lui parler de son travail
le thé est servi
rester dans la
pourquoi
bertrand pris la voiture était ici s'il
te plaît
eh bien
si vous parlez ont un peu de ses enfants
ça y est je suis contente de travailler
et je n'ai pas fait exprès aucune
importance seul le résultat compte il me
semble que je rêve
cet hiver à courir les balles et enfin
ça y est je crois un caucus écoute si je
veux passer migraine au lit je m'en
fiche c'est toi qui m'intéressent ma
chérie je trouve un peu pâle tout le
couvre-feu une angine par hasard or en
tous les cas toutes ces émotions vives
brisé rien mon petit amour je vais te
coucher je déborderait comme autrefois
quand tu étais petite fille
reste le problème de la dot je n'ai
qu'une parole aux autres de la cnil
c'est ça que vous appelez frotter dont
je me refuse à défendre les acquis du
crâne et j'ai fait ni en série à
j'aurais voulu la voir chez nous comme
nous allons affronter la thune fallait
marcher droit
moi donc je ne travaille pas pour vous
je travaille pour rendre service alors
il ne faut pas comment fait il me manque
mais tu sais où nous avons mis là bien
du grenier surveille surveille
nous guettons une femme depuis ce matin
vient de chez ce menuisier là au seul
ouvrier que nous ayons dans la maison
dire merci et même si le propriétaire
m'écoutait ne garderait pas ça chez lui
pour 100 francs par mois
ça vaut vraiment pas la peine d'avoir de
la saleté chez soi la voilà et où la
femme
d'où venez vous je suis le concierge de
l'immeuble
nous ne voulons pas ça entendez-vous on
l'a déjà dit à l'homme ils vous emmènent
si vous ramenez j'irai chercher un
sergent de bulles et nous verrons s'il
vous fallait encore vos cauchemars dans
une maisonnette pour vous vos billets
raciste mais vous voyez comment ça parle
macler monsieur cours le couple est à
huy faudra plus haut j'y pense je vais
cachés sous les chemises pour que les
bonnes soient pas toujours fourré dans
l'ensemble mon corps quelque chose de
propre os est bonne la macif mais je
vous serais reconnaissant de me
descendre car il ne peut pas y avoir un
coin d'ouvert sont que des bonnes
actions à conduire
[Musique]
oui elles en sont capables j'en ai
trouvé détendu sur leur lit en plein
milieu de la journée
je n'ai pas sûr mais surtout qu'on
aurait vu des choses pareilles 1 on se
tenait pour ses maîtres monsieur mouret
on se tenait
vous moi
plus avec la cuisinière une femme de 40
ans un corps mon cher vous m'éclairer
nom du temps un garçon comme vous qui
pourraient prétendre un certain choix
tout de même mais julie est une ville
très bien regarder un peu ça c'est pas
chic
ouais c'est peut-être chic mais c'est
voler sa vie est un droit des armoires
de sa patronne vous n'êtes jamais
content mais moi tant pis je lui parle
les trompettes juil
parce qu'à des l'cie se souvient on
compte tout plaisante et pourquoi vous
cacher à la
il voit la quantité
la fête du matin au caire par la
déculottée je crois bien qu'elle m'a dit
c'est pas très académiques tellement
dégoûté la faille y en avoir une
indigestion
si nous faisons pour nous amuser le
quart de ce que pensent et demoiselles
pour attraper un mari ou encore vous
allez bien vous n'avez rien vu
il y avait signé il ne panique pas fait
mauvais effet et regarder les hommes par
le coût de ces rues menant à la place de
bert joris fichu des claques à l'auguste
jolie patrick celui là avec ses
migraines travailler et pour passer les
films assure j'ai toujours à nous et
spiriteux gamine pourra bientôt plus qu
j'ai cru que c'était manager
elles sont toutes à tremper dans des
cuvettes l'or pour les occupent trop
pour quelle soja nous embêter c'est le
seul moment de la journée pour respirer
un peu et chez vous enfin toujours la
même chose
vive les buffets alors grand sera
l'architecte qu'est ce qui fait baisser
au sol avec la couche tard les voilà la
nouvelle vous installez mademoiselle je
torche mademoiselle je tâche mais cette
cuisine et si déroutante
vous aurez la constance il vous restait
la dernière on aura des pleurs et dit si
robert est quoi ce ne sera pas long
merci quand même dur en fait main donkey
punch bourgeois et bien de partir des
déchets vie marine
on la connaît son ami de déceler la tête
en bas et les jambes en l'air
et là on ne peut pas faire attention
la torsion vous viendrez skouma célèbre
cela n'en rend que ça soit pas des vies
dures de poissons comme l'autre jour tu
sûr commun se débarbouiller avec vous
êtes toujours à prévoir dans marié ta
maîtresse c'est toi qui lui apprend à
faire les hommes
celle-là rester dans une maison on mange
pas et là serge peu pour lui pardonner
ici ma faute si je mange pas ok toujours
faim vous allez donc couché là on vers
d'une maison bourgeoise avoué
vocabulaire mise à part que ce n'est pas
très différent de l'endroit mon voeu de
m'être laissé prendre dorures de
l'escalier quand je suis arrivé ici par
âge j'avais cru rentrer dans un temple
sans indiscrétion quelques vous voulez
faire dans le secteur
rassurez-vous pas de concurrence
quand je suis venu chercher des livres
dans mes mal vous en direct en sortant
oublié de fermer à clé j'aimerais
revenir ce soir
les bons jours je gâter votre d'eiffage
voulez pas vous déranger
oui ce sont des livres voilà vous
permettez oui bien sûr je pense que
marie sera très content dépêchons-nous
avec cette pluie l'omnibus heures à
bondy j'espère qu'il vous plaira je les
ai choisis spécialement pour vous
viens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça nous dessert devenu fia dans ma
chambre
paris je te par toi tu ne peux rien
faire de mal
c'est vrai tout est pure opus si j'étais
super tout ça j'aurais pas en deux
devant jules des cafés à défaut
sois gentil
ne goûte pas tu me dis que nous avons
deux heures devant nous comment que tu
en es tu aussi sûr parce qu'il pleut il
sera plus de raccompagner les parents à
pied jusqu à montmartre le dessus alors
s'il n'y a plus de place dans l'omnibus
il y en a dans ma chambre tu ne veux
plus
si je fais bien ça ne te plaît plus où
cette plaie ça me plaît alors
je voudrais simplement que tu me le non
plus en fait tu voudrais que je ne
t'aime plus au contraire je voudrais que
tu m'aimes tellement que j'en arrive à
oublier ces choses là qui me paraît
difficile je sais doit sûrement y avoir
quelque chose ou quelqu'un qui vous aide
à faire les choses difficiles passées
bien en tout cas j'essaierai une vue de
priver de rien tu comprends mais je me
dis que peut-être si j'étais plus douce
plus gentil c'est le café des meilleurs
n'y penserai plus je pourrai regarder je
le sors ma serait si content d'être à
l'aise marier ce que tu te moques en
fait on problème si je comprends bien ce
serait de me combler en me privant de
tout certaines fiches sont
c'était mal quand on se marie nous
pourquoi
ça y est ils vont marier berthe l'autre
je m'en fiche
sa fille une berthe
je veux pas plus face du mal
le dedans de ses mains c'est doux comme
du papier à lettres s'étonner qu'un oui
vous avez raison
calmons nous je vais les tuer tous
alternera avec un couteau
donc tout ce qu'on veut me ferais rien
de pareil dit saturn
parce que vous êtes un bon garçon que
vous voulez de mal à personne pourquoi
on avait à berne
gros bêta croyez que monsieur le curé la
marée rhin c'était mal elle le fera pas
vous avez raison
d'ailleurs je serai à l'église si les
béni je lui saute dessus je bouscule et
l'enferment dans un placard
il sera bien étonné le pauvre il le fera
pas vous avez raison il ne fera pas
allez-vous oui
je crois même que je vais bien dormir
tu vois là
il arrive tout excité puissantes ondes
très calme mais je l'envoie plus de
quelques jours
miraculeuse d'où sa tête bien qu'un jour
tu me donneras aussi un toit qui pleure
en d'armes
papa il s'en remet pas monsieur barbe de
tous mais le propriétaire va vous
manquer la porte
de quoi à la porte quand je paye mon
terme je voudrais bien voir ça par
exemple là vous allez vous attend dès
l'aube à la guinée sans plus passer par
bas
et si monsieur touche on va rire mais
c'est la vie du salon vous voyez
monsieur je vous l'avais dit que des
gens de là ou à la porte
je ne veux pas de femmes dans la maison
entendez-vous mais c'est la mienne
commence à la vôtre de biens puis la
mienne elle est en place elle vient me
rejoindre une fois par mois comme ses
maîtres le permettent
où est le mal vous n'allez tout de même
pas empêché un mari de coucher avec sa
femme
pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas dit qui ça
regarde ça regarde l'honnêteté monsieur
vous êtes d'une insolence m'avoir laissé
croire que vraiment c'est pas
supportable je vous chasse monsieur
entendez vous vous pouvez aller faire
vos paquets je ne vois pas pourquoi on
prie n'aggravez pas votre cas respectez
au moins mes cheveux blancs à défaut
d'autre chose
bon ça va pour les cheveux blancs
d'accord bien
qui reviendra plus la mairie nous
trouverons un autre endroit pour faire
notre garçon mais tout de même c'est un
peu fort pas de femme dans sa colère à
chaque étage des [ __ ] bien mise qui
va du petit chien derrière époque elle
seule chose que le pape et pianos neufs
based on se refuse à orcières faut bien
se mettre au niveau des barres ne te
plaît en moins allez les enfants
laissez-nous nous avons à parler avec
votre oncle
veulent embrasser ou bien ça c'est mon
fiancé il te plait il est moins neuf que
le piano garde tes plaisanterie pour le
repas de noces je compte sur un feu
roulant
assieds toi toi aussi joseph tu n'es pas
trop j'ai pris mes renseignements voici
où en sont les vab le vieux attiré un
demi million de la vente de son étude
si la maison lui a coûté 300 mille
francs il doit lui en restait 200 villes
qui depuis 12 ans produisent des
intérêts en outre il a chaque année 22
mille francs de loyer et comme il vit
chez sa fille sans dépenser le tas voir
au bas mot 5 à 600 mille francs plus la
maison donc de ce côté de belles
espérances
il joue pas à la bourse mais non un
vieux si tranquille quant à auguste je
crois savoir qu'il touchera 50 mille
francs le jour du contrat mais ne faut
pas trop y compter
ce sera déjà bien beau si le père lui
fais grâce des termes du magasin pendant
quelques années et en suit aujourd'hui
on sait le mariage pour les parents
revenons à auguste ces affaires ne
marchent pas mal il veut s'agrandir
il faut dont une jolie femme derrière le
comptoir c'est pour soi qu'il a pensé à
berthe calcul n'est pas mauvais elle a
tout ce qu'il faut pour attirer le
chaland
elle est gracieuse et marc joly et la
dot des cinquante mille francs
non tout à fait décider qu'est ce que tu
penses de saint-narcisse vous emballez
vous en parle c'est à dire qu'est ce que
voulez que je vous dise est toujours
rêvé pour ma filleule de quelqu'un de
beaucoup mieux et il a 33 ans passés il
est toujours malade et avec c'est une
humeur de chien et des migraines qui me
laisse aucun répit puisque elle veut
elle veut
le veut et permet oui si je la dot
j'ai moi aussi mon mot à dire elle me
plait pas le prétendu voilà pour la
franchise
j'en demande à d'autres un autre mmo
j'ai déjà remet tous parés pour trouver
celui là on peut encore attendre combien
de temps tu sais les filles il faut
toujours avoir l'oeil sur sa montre elle
a déjà 21 ans
en quelques mois elle fera figure
d'invendus oh non non non c'est une
occasion inespérée
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire si auguste
ne s'était pas présenté j'allais donner
ma langue au chat
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dise
c'est plus fort que moi avec auguste
j'aurais prend l'impression en avant
pour 58 francs soyons sérieux
comptant sur ton bon coeur et sur tes
promesses je me suis engagée à verser 50
mille francs
tu ne vas pas nous lâcher maintenant tu
vois bien dans quelle situation tu nous
mais c'est impossible
tu parles toujours deux premières jusque
sur la tombe de notre mère ah non ça
suffit
est ce qu on sait ce qu'on dit dans des
moments pareils on est tellement
bouleversée c'est odieux ne spéculez sur
des émotions aussi respectable
d'ailleurs déjà le lendemain
j'en parlais plus 50 fois tu nous l'a
répété
de toute façon cette discussion
utilities g par jour
allende je connais vos affaires vous
gagner gros comme vous et vous rue
laurier sur l'ours et vous ne jetez pas
par les fenêtres moi je ne vous demande
rien s'est il alors qui a voulu faire
cette démarche
mais permettez moi de vous dire bas cela
que vous vous êtes bien fichu nous
depuis 15 ans chaque samedi
quand vous me demander de venir vérifier
gratuitement vos comptes
vous êtes toujours à me promettre de 1o
m parler peut-être mais promettre en
franchement je ne crois pas jamais mais
faites moi confiance et vous verrez un
jour berthe apprendre à connaître le
coeur de son oncle en attendant grâce au
coeur de son oncle elle restera vieille
fille et et l'assurance de talent
enterré depuis 14 ans tu le sais bien
d'ailleurs jamais dépassé la 4eme prime
les vagues ne sont pas obligés de le
savoir
on parle de cette assurance et puis on
prend son temps pour ptt caen est en fin
de compte on ne peut jamais une doc
c'est tout ce que vous avez trouvé
mais jamais je vous le jure est ce que
le père bachelard feu mon père vous a
jamais payer la dot d'eléonore c'est une
saleté que vous me proposez la passe je
mentirais je ferai un faux en montrant
ce contrat comme tu t'emballes mon ami
personne ne demande de faire un faux et
bien je vous en montrer les papiers on
en parle de tout et s'agit simplement de
gagner du temps du promet la dot nous la
donnerons plus tard si narcisse est gêné
en ce moment est la raison dans le fond
n'ont tout de même pas déranger ses
affaires pour faire plaisir aux vabre
non non ça je ne mettrai jamais le pied
sur ce salon on ordonne temps je me
retrouverais dans la peau d'un escroc je
n'ai pas de dot a donné je ne promets
pas et le mariage sera rompu je voudrais
bien voir ça par exemple
écoute moi bien joseph ce mariage est la
dernière chance de ma fille je me
couperais plutôt le poignet que deux
morts
et tant pis pour les autres après tout
ainsi madame en suivant ce beau
raisonnement pour marié votre fille vous
assassine aurier oui nous approchons
nous approchons bien situé
moi je me charge de la négociation c'est
du verrier qu'il faut voir après je
verrai du attention il est très fort
l'entrevue risque d'être difficile elle
en sera que plus intéressante
nous commencerons par lui à que joseph
me céder sa place parce que je pense
qu'il entend rien aux affaires ce que
tout le monde qu'on a facilement et non
non non je ne marche pas non non et non
oui mais à la condition que vous ne
fassiez rien faire contre 1 2510 avec
vous rassure aujourd'hui de toute façon
c'est une simple prise de contact
mango faire se réserve de faire bien des
largesses au jeune couple
mais sur le plan des certitudes il ne
veut s'engager content qu'il est sûr de
pouvoir tenir
on saurait demander plus brillants dont
les certitudes
pour le reste je fais toute confiance à
monsieur jo sera rayon certitude
cinquante mille francs cette somme est
représenté par une assurance d'autant la
déchéance de 20 ans que josserand a mis
sur la tête de sa fille lorsqu'elle
avait 4 ans elle le doit à son toucher
la somme que dans trois ans permettez
lycées - fils est exclu du verrier
comprends parfaitement mais comme si
l'enfant peuvent avoir besoin d'argent
tout de suite
nous nous engageons appuyer la dot par
échéance de dix mille francs de six mois
en six mois quitte alors en bon c'est
plus tard en touchant le capital assuré
les vençois me paraît très bien c'est à
nous de vous remercier
il est rare qu'une date se fait
intégralement jamais me suis jamais ça
ne se fait pas hélas ces conditions il
ne reste plus qu'à convoquer le notaire
et je relis avec l'accord des deux
parties la dot de 50 mille francs
accordés par la famille josserand sera
versée par engagement tacite ladite
famille s'engage à régler par échéance
de dix mille francs de six mois en six
mois le premier versement interviendra
donc six mois après mariage soit le 12
mars 1865
en ce qui concerne les acquis ils sont
alors d'avrillé peut-être pourrait-on
mentionner ici la nature de la garantie
l'assurance et je ferai tout ce qu'on
voudra
à quoi bon quand bien même il me semble
que nos signatures couvrent tout je peux
poursuivre l'instant je vous prie je
voudrais ajouter ma surprise à celle de
mon frère qu'est ce que c'est que cette
assurance une assurance de talent chère
madame mais j'ai jamais entendu parler
de ça monsieur bachelard qui devait
payer la note
vous m'avez mal compris chère madame il
n'en a jamais été question
je vous demande bien par nous avons
pensé je n'aurais jamais engagé mon
frère pour une somme aussi médiocre
c'est toute sa fortune qu'il donnera
berthe
un jour on roule en gérant un mystère
c'est vrai un jour bertrand a tous je
veux bien le croire mais ça n'a rien
d'un contrat je ne sais pas ce qu'on
pense mon frère mais si c'était moi je
ferais modifier celui ci
je ne vois pas ma chère amie pourquoi
vous exigez plus d'engagement que votre
père noël a pris avec moi dois je
comprendre que ce qui est assez bon pour
moi devrait pas l'être pour les autres
cela risquerait de nous on est assez
loin ou si vous préférez faisons venir
votre père il nous dira si ce contrat
brave l'honnêteté et nous nous suivrons
son conseil
après tout il est orfèvre en la matière
m vous pouvez poursuivre en ce qui
concerne les acquis ils sont la
propriété commune aux deux époux est
encore de séparation divisé en deux
parts égales une pour chacun des
conjoints
or voilà c'est vous n'allez tout de même
pas varier votre fille avec cette figure
d'enterrement tenez sur ce que j'ai le
plus sacré l'oncle paiera les dix
premiers milles francs gens répondent ou
l'a formellement premier en sortant de
chez le notaire
le soir de ce jour un fiacre vain
cherché saturnin le mariage de sa soeur
avait accru sans dérangement mental il
devenait dangereux et monsieur josserand
le coeur crever avait dû demander son
admission à l'asile les moulineaux chez
le docteur chassagne
il passa la nuit à faire des bandes au
petit jour dans le frisson du matin il
achevait son deuxième 1000 et gagné 6
francs plusieurs fois il avait levé la
tête comme d'habitude pour écouter ci
saturnin or mieux points dans la pièce à
côté puis la pensée de berthe lui
donnait une nouvelle fleur le travail
pauvre petit
elle aurait voulu être en noir blanche
enfin avec 6 francs elle pourrait mettre
davantage à son bouquet
[Musique]